you don't have any soap no you ever
check things out because you know the on
social no like I have a fake account on
Instagram or I can like follow my
friends around the world and see what
they're doing so I see that but I don't
I don't work this debate like I don't
post photos your posts on that a zero
and I don't follow people I don't know
so I my knowledge listen my husband came
home like four weeks ago and was like do
you know what Netflix and chill me and I
was like yeah like watch Netflix and my
good Chinese food and he was like no it
means Netflix and have like that's how
late we are on all three round culture
when he's on social media is on at like
night nobody's like not surfing the web
not like looking up I mean the fact that
I said I genuinely thought Netflix and
chill and I had a pepper Twitter it's
not it's not I have a mess [ __ ] sweater
- such a chill across it and I wear all
the time it's absolutely I'm wearing
things on my chest like ward out
shopping for like always yes and I just
learned that I mean have sex mask on or
tiny food well we go this way to show
what I mean mom come on idea what is
that it doesn't mean Chinese food is all
I'm going to say any vegetarian
yeah you need your cupcake shop so that
mom this is the reincarnation of
Christmas version book wick you haven't
started filming yet at all I'm sorry
your script we have a script do we have
a Kevin with a cat okay same cast
everyone coming back this we mustn't go
back to Kathryn Hahn Kristen Bell myself
are coming back and we're adding our
mothers into our cellar doses October
Jane is not going back Napa gates not
coming back and anyone looks like my
back you know it's a very different
orderings okay what can we expect from a
story this time around it's going to
involve our mothers so it's going to be
my my mom yeah where's your mom I can't
believe your mom you're gonna really
send it what happens in a job maybe
something like that
okay I really can't say does she look
like I just got a whole conversation I
got done talking to some SPX that I
cannot tell you does she look like you
yeah
yes she does yeah oh yeah maybe we can
put a couple people up I wish I had a
headshot you could sell and see how you
react you should ask if you interview
anyone to my chance see what one day
will tell you I played with this old I
can't tell you anything why is this
something you wanted to come back to do
again I love making the movie and love
the girls I love the idea of it I love
the wish fulfillment of motherhood I
think it's actually like a nice outlet
for and gives women a voice it's great
it's so relatable I mean your kids a
little bit older than our you still like
making mistakes oh it's all perfect it's
exactly a year older so the movie takes
place almost as if you never left so
from time to time it's going to be
exactly a year later what about you
yourself as a mom mom is it now that
they're old is it clean saline you know
and a half is not older two and a half a
cylinder but they're walking around and
doing smelly and she's running she's not
walking yet you're saving the clinic not
too crazy now it's a matter of like
teaching manners and like you know
instilling like good morals or things
like that she's infected
like so much